if you don't believe American needs
secure borders you're the enemy of
America you need secure who doesn't know
you need secure borders Nancy Pelosi
doesn't Hillary Clinton didn't Loretta
Lynch didn't I mean come on these people
are freaks
America first pisses off Democrats how
can that be if it's not America think
you lose it as you're denying
opportunity to people that live in an
impoverished third-world country that's
connected to us they think of it as
racism all my ancestors came through
Ellis Island as did mine and denounced
their allegiance to where they came from
you can still cook Swedish and still
cook German but you gotta denounce
allegiance to where you come from
because you come in here it's [ __ ]
hard for someone to come over from
Mexico and don't you think that the real
problem is that Mexico sucks that parts
of Mexico so overall to figure out a way
to help those people really the only way
would be to make Mexico so healthy and
in a great place to live that it's just
like the United States there's no reason
to come over here and certainly we have
tried our policies have been very
generous to those countries in fact were
the only country that has been generous
to them but the roughly the right yeah
there's a [ __ ] chinstrap
yeah mass across the entire Mexican
Guatemalan that all those governments
are as criminals Al Capone in Chicago in
32 I've been so infested by the law
enforcement is the cartel the military
is the kind of tough so so where are you
so that line of X we have the right to
secure this is not my opinion we in
America have the right and the
responsibility to secure our borders if
you think otherwise you're dangerous we
need to break I want people who need a
better quality of life I'd welcome them
I got buddies that game like that Mike
my sound man Frank went through the
seven-year process from Germany and now
he's a legal citizen in America why
should someone be able to swim across
the Rio Grande and circumvent all that
process so we
whether you're going to be an asset or a
liability it's not rocket science it's
liability or asset we want assets and
that's why our immigration system is
horrifically legal one so I know it's a
problem but we're putting all these
resources and man-hours into securing
the poorest border instead of processing
those who legitimately would like a
better quality of life in America but
first they have to we have to
differentiate between the protesters who
think that we need to turn over
California in Arizona and Texas back to
Mexico so it can turn into a [ __ ] of
course they left Mexico they know it's
horrible that's why they're here
why would you come here to get away from
a [ __ ] and then turn the place you
came to into the [ __ ] we have a
constitution we have a Bill of Rights
you need to earn your own way you need
to work very hard if you're in the asset
column I love you if you're in the
liability column I love you if you're
having hard times but if you have
squatted intentionally as an able-bodied
individual in that liability column you
are a detriment to America and you
should get the [ __ ] out of here
that's when you look at in perspective
the people that are able-bodied
Americans that don't do jack [ __ ] poor
bastard is trying to yeah anything they
can to get here from Mexico to the point
where they're literally dying in a
hydration desert yeah and they would
bust their ass if given that opportunity
it's not fair it's not easy it's not
gonna be easy tom placated right but it
is doable but our priorities as a
government are so clustered there so dis
prioritized that all this efforts going
towards you know securing the Rio Grande
when people are illegally swimming
across and jeopardizing their very life
and limb when just down a couple miles
there's a legal entrance and it might be
a pain in the ass but you're here with
me today June 28 2020 18 have you not
put up with major pains in the asses of
martial artists as a comedian that's a
tough life
you got your world carved out because
you put up with a pain in the ass and
you over you improvise adapt and
overcome it makes you happier at night
do that very fortunate I was born in
America I you know I didn't grow up in
an impoverished crime-ridden community
understood to deal with gang violence
but you're certainly not advocating them
coming in illegally no I just think
there's got to be there's got to be a
better conversation about this and I
think that the conversation is that if
you oppose these people that are illegal
immigrating into this country that
you're a racist so